los republicanos se han mostrado muy
críticos a cómo ha avanzado esta este
proceso esta investigación de los
documentos confidenciales que fueron
encontrados en la oficina de llenura de
las oficinas de Joe biden aquí en
Washington también el garaje de su casa
privada en Delaware los republicanos en
el congreso Ya abrieron una
investigación pero se están quejando de
que precisamente haber designado ya a un
consejo especial para llevar a cabo esta
investigación limitará el acceso el
procedimiento y el alcance que tenga la
investigación que haga lo republicanos
en el congreso los republicanos también
se están quejando de que la
administración Se demoró mucho en
revelar esta información a pesar de que
la conocía ya hace algunos meses en
cuanto a similitudes Pues es de de de
Resaltar que pues los dos mandatarios se
llevaron información confidencial de la
casa blanca de que hubo mal manejo y que
se descuidó esta información
confidencial en sus lugares privados en
cuanto Pues es de Resaltar que Donald
Trump a pesar de los llamados del
gobierno no entregó la información a
tiempo cuando se le solicitó algo
diferente a lo que ha hecho biden quien
no solamente ha entregado la información
requerida sino que ha dicho que quiere
cooperar con la justicia Bueno ayer el
fiscal general
designó a Robert como fiscal
especializado en el caso ya usted lo
estaba mencionando cuéntenos de la
trayectoria de
50 años es de Nueva York se educó en
Harvard y en Stanford el en este momento
trabaja en el sector privado como pues
eh abogado privado de casos similares a
este es decir él ya conoce este tipo de
clientes trabajó como fiscal de distrito
de Maryland durante el 2018 y 2021 antes
Estuvo trabajando para la administración
de Donald Trump trabajó cerca de un año
para
el departamento de Justicia durante la
administración de Donald Trump y pues es
un abogado acá en Washington que muchos
conocen que le han confiado este caso
precisamente por la cercanía que tiene
con este tipo de clientes y este tipo de
casos